he'll be all right though of course it'd
be all right i i didn't i i didn't buy
the controversy really
with the golden globes i think that was
the press just keeping it going because
i was really offended who did i really
offend you know
i was there i think you offended
and there's so many stupid people on
twitter
it's great yeah someone said
uh hey you're worth 80 million but you
haven't had your teeth fixed
and i sent back
when you're this rich you get your
butler to chew your food
all right clark again robert de niro oh
are you looking at me all right uh
arnold schwarzenegger i'll be back uh
well the winston churchill oh i'll fight
them on the beaches i will uh kim
kardashian oh look at these
is it true the the story about getting
the call from stephen hawking yeah yeah
well i did i got a call from this guy
how'd you know it was him yeah
but when you come to the united states
uh is it are you nervous about traveling
these days for example well i'd say with
the first time um i was a bit
apprehensive coming to the states this
time a couple of reasons really the
first one is i mean obviously since the
war in iraq um it's not good to be in
america with a french name oh um but uh
i am uh i have got french blood i
do you watch doctor who i don't know
killed that one didn't it
was there is that really all you had
you've lost a lot of weight thank you
how have you done it tell me a secret
steroids and aids
uh how long is your i'm not asking how
long is
i'm not seven inches all right well
listen
here's one you tweeted of jane jane
thought she'd made a new friend
but it was just a shadow
jane thinking about making new friends
this one is uh jane is looking so happy
because her new friend hasn't walked
away yet
what is the dumbest thing you've ever
done while you were drunk
i thought of what i just thought of one
i don't know if it's dumbest um i i um
i knew you'd have a good answer for them
i um i weed on my girlfriend once
no let me explain
there had to be there had been a few
words at home after you posted this one
just found this photo of jane when she
was little
there had to be a gift you must have
given her a gift after that yeah well
there you go
i can't believe this uh you you had a
birthday and is it 50 years old you're
not 50 years old are you really 50 50
50. yeah i mean you look tremendous
you look like you're 35 if somebody
hadn't seen me uh how old is it it's a
35 a 35 honestly you look exactly like
you did the first except you're in
better shape remember you used to come
out you sort of pear-shaped when you
come out
now you look
great you look you didn't say that at
the time though no i didn't know
i didn't know what to think well no you
said well you look good now because i
looked awful before that's all you're
saying
i needed you to say it before you've got
your pear-shaped worked out faster
how do you feel at 50 good right oh yeah
i'm grumpier i think i'm grumpier yeah
yeah i understand you a lot more now did
i meet
what's uh the a body part you're most
proud of on yourself
um
it's probably um
[Music]
my second penis
no um
wow
my next brother's like 11 years older
than 12 my sister's 12 years old and my
older brother's like 13 years older i
mean i remember asking my mum why that
was i was about like 11 eating my
cornflakes and i said um mum why are my
brothers and sisters so much older than
me and she said because you were a
mistake
just like that do you think maybe if at
60 it'll get even worse i don't know
because you said i looked better than i
did at 40. oh you look much better than
you did when i first met you so if this
carries on if you looked at a graph yeah
i should be i'd look like johnny depp
when i'm about 70.
that's right yeah
yeah call me when that happens
because you've never been to australia
it's too far
no and what this guy here i don't know
they don't no don't that's it america if
you keep sitting with your legs like
that i'm going to get you some tickets
to a broadway show
yeah
thank you
i can't move it because i'll crush the
sloth
right you're a is that is that a sex
thing crushing him
all right
you're you're a what what is he a gay
robot skeleton yeah right i can see he's
caesar skeletons he's a robot his name's
jeff but what what have you done this
guy
come over here and i'll show you
and this policeman comes out with a
mirror on the end of a stick and he
looks under the van like that and as
he's doing it his helmet falls off
and
20 cigarettes fell out
and the the copper looked at bob and
sort of went he went i bet you've always
wondered what we kept under our helmets
and bob went i knew it wasn't [ __ ]
brains
i thought some of these cat pictures
actually were quite convincing
that's good that's one that's a good one
it's the next one let's see let's keep
going and then that's a nice one then
there's three there's another one right
here and i like that a lot look at that
that's fantastic
oh my god
i just wondered if there was a guy that
oh no that's gone a bit far oh yeah i
mean
but you know
you think the things i say are terrible
think of the things i think
yeah they're very good
listen i'm with you
with this god thing like our whitney was
in uh yeah
i mean but there's a bit of you thinks
you know what if it is true what do you
do when you meet god forgive me will he
yeah and it's his fault why did he make
me an atheist
[Music]
i can't believe it this is true
[Music]
you uh you blame johnny jett for ruining
your hair um no i played um
a tiny prostitute part in public enemies
for a day you're having a dwarf
there's not even any water here can i
have a drink of water
unfortunately oh you've got some well no
brilliant yeah i bought this myself you
have to buy your own out of bbc that's a
queen you want that's a pound i want
from you that's a pound
okay let's do an interview
i never knew you were this weird really
because you
i eat and drink too much every night and
then i go to the gym and everything
aches though because i run my knees gone
my shoulders you gotta use that machine
now oh everything's gone
this machine yeah the frog leg machine
yeah yeah
that's the one i do now because it
doesn't hurt my knees i have to do that
yeah i've got to be so careful you have
just getting older you're the same age i
know i know
yes yes that's five i've had five years
of the finger yeah i've had five years
of the fingernails well you you started
late you start in america you start 40.
no yeah yeah you start no the testicles
sort of go out the end of the 40s then
you're out of that danger and then the
50s start the the old the old
so
so now that's the exact noise main mix
yeah yeah right right okay talking about
being recognized and it's had in
restaurants being recognized when you're
having that done is great so i was
having it done once and um it was a
there was a doctor right and we've done
other things he goes um uh do you want
me to protest your prostate yes and i
said yeah fine he said um do you need a
chaperone i went no no finally okay so
he does that and he went
big fan by the way
we we have these reality game shows
there's so many of them you're getting
there there's celebrities and stuff well
celebrities you say celebrities but now
it's there's they've done so many that
it's like siblings of celebrities and
next-door neighbors and you know sons
and daughters of celebrities and there
was one in particular and i was talking
to kyle and i said the thing is with him
he said i said he's only famous because
of who his dad was and carl said yeah
but you could say the same about jesus
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hello tiny tim
hello
oh
i bet it looks even worse than that keep
going
right
see